hello everyone how you guys doing hope
you guys are having a wonderful day
today we're here with another video in
today's video we will be going over what
you should and what you should not
invest into going into the release of
old-school mobile so old school
runescape Mobile is an app that is
planned to be released in winter of 2017
and so basically that means either
December January February so one of the
next one two three months with that said
this is going to change the game
entirely as far as what people are
training whenever they're online because
it will allow a lot more access to a
scalable skills that people normally
wouldn't have been training so what
we'll be going over today is practically
what is going to go up and what's going
to go down in regard to almost every
skill within the game most skills are
affected for the most part stuff like
construction and high clique intensive
skills aren't going to be as infected
aren't going to be as affected as stuff
like fishing and cooking that's
obviously really afk and more prone to
be done on an app with that said I will
be focusing more on higher-level content
more so than lower levels I know a lot
of people like to anticipate what the
low levels will be doing and what all of
the noobs coming to old-school mobile
will be doing on the app but more than
likely the way I see it is most people
that will be playing the app will be
people already playing the game anyone
actually finds old-school mobile on the
App Store and plays it they're gonna
realize it's way too much for them and
they probably can't stay within the game
I mean there's just so much to do and
there's so much to learn that to do it
on a phone just is not the right way to
go about it most people that actually
only end up playing mainly foam would be
people that played before and for the
most part I'm going to assume that
that's a relatively small amount however
if you see differently feel free to
invest as you please so overall I guess
you can go buy an attack strength
defense HP and Slayer pretty much all
into one it's going to be kind of the
same thing and what I would recommend is
that people are going to be afk in
combat skills whether that be Slayer or
just being a nightmare zone and actually
just AF getting their actual combat
skills overall what I see this doing is
pretty much hiking the price of whatever
high tier armor you can get your hands
on as long as it's related to melee for
the most part I think all that's going
to go up and may not go up a ton like
obviously whips aren't gonna jump from
1.6 1.7 million oh maybe they go over
the 2 mil mark because a lot of people
are going to want to afk whenever
they're not near their computer and more
than likely they'll do it in the form of
melee since that's one of the most
favorable skills within the game and one
of
most fun to Train some side-effects of
this I would say in the long run Slayer
drops are going to go down in price but
it's not going to be something you have
to worry about necessarily right off the
bat as more and more people can I have
case Slayer on a phone obviously they're
going to be higher and higher level thus
allowing them to get more drops and
they'll be getting them more often as
they're playing more so overall the
price of drops are going to go down on
top of that nightmare zone one thing I
will say is people are gonna probably be
buying their daily herb boxes and it may
affect the price of herbs a little bit
but not a whole lot coming to the game
through that and you have to rely a lot
on people buying their dailies so it
could be something that happens now one
thing I do want to add that isn't really
related to any skill in total dailies
overall will be something that people
will do so something like farming
obviously people are going to want to do
more farm runs which will decrease the
price of herbs and increase the price of
herb seeds and on top of that you'll
have people buying their daily battle
staffs more and more which will allow
for battle staff prices to go down and
probably charge or prices will go up a
little bit moving down the list as far
as range is concerned the only real
things I see happening here or possibly
Zoro skills going up because people are
going to be afk with a blowpipe in
nightmare zone and on top of that you
could have gin prices go up if anything
I would say chin prices wouldn't go down
because there's really no reason for it
but people could be afk Chin's more and
more while they are on their phone so
that's one thing that you can look out
for now as far as Pryor is concerned I
thought that the bones were going to go
up because more people were going to
want to afk Pryor while they were on
their app but one thing that's recently
happened is we now have a poll for
wilderness rejuvenation and now there
will be a temple in the wilderness where
you can offer bones and have a chance to
receive 50% of them back
so overall the price of Dragon bones are
going to drop pretty heavily over time
and on top of that people will be
camping a lot of wyvern so those two
factors combined will make it so that
bone prices actually go down now as far
as magic there are a lot of methods that
people could be doing while they're on
their phone stuff like Al King and a lot
of stuff like that but most magic
methods actually have pretty much pretty
easily capped prices as far as that goes
and they don't vary all too much one
thing I would recommend though if you
want to get ahead go ahead and invest in
unstrung amulets whether that be unholy
symbols or unshown Golding emulates both
of those are going to go up because
people are going to want to afk a
strange jewelry method which allows for
a lot of magic XP and it is really afk
now I'm going to skip over runecrafting
in construction neither of the
really have a huge impact on the economy
as far as it goes with this update one
thing I will say though Bloods and souls
will be easier to craft but Bloods are
pretty much trapped at whatever price
they are now because you can sell them
to a shop for 200 GP and souls are
relatively low at 142 P per one so I
don't see them changing all too much
now in regards to thieving thieving is
obviously going to be one that is really
nice to do on mobile but it won't have a
real impact on the economy more goal
will be coming into the game but it's so
seldom that it really won't be anything
that you'll see impact as far as agility
and herb-lore obviously you could do
agility on mobile I would imagine too
many people would do it but if it is
something that a lot of people do
emily's could go down in price but
really I don't see that happening as far
as herblore goes as I said earlier herb
prices are probably going to drop which
means you might be able to get some
different margins but for the most part
not a whole lot to see there now as far
as crafting is concerned there's really
nothing you can invest in for this
battle staff prizes as I said before
more than likely go down and with people
being able to camp I guess or afk Green
Dragons and blue dragons you'll have a
lower price of most of the dragon
Heights one thing I would say is you'll
probably be able to make more money off
of tanning dragon Heights if you want to
go ahead and do that as a money-making
method that's going to be one that will
be better after the update and on top of
that you may be able to get a little
less GP / XP for crafting after this
update comes out so that may be worth it
to wait on for you now one thing that's
going to change the game obviously is
fletching fletching in two ways is going
to be huge upon release
so one thing that people can actually
look out for is for dart tips to go up
now those are going to just boom on day
of release because people are going to
want to see what they can do on mobile
but go ahead and invest of that as you
please
this is a very common and a very easy to
see investment so a lot of people may
already be in on it and may to be too
late but if you want to go ahead and try
it feel free another thing I will say is
the overall price of unstrung bows will
be going down because a lot more people
will be AF getting fletching on this app
and that's the price of unstrung is
going to go down now if you're willing
to sit on the computer though you will
make a lot more money by actually making
the unshrunk into actual bows by putting
them together with both strings so if
you want to do that as a method make
sure to keep that in mind next up I
already covered Slayer and as far as
hunter goes that's not going to be
something anyone
is going to want to do on mobile I would
imagine there are obviously some
exceptions to that but for the most part
it's not something that's going to be
more fun on mobile now next up is mining
mining obviously is going to be one that
a lot of people would do with mother
lode mine or price is probably going to
go down so I'd stay away from those but
it is definitely a method that's going
to be very viable upon release of this
update and it's going to be something I
would recommend a lot of people to do
because it's going to be so easy and so
afk next up is smithing smithing there's
not a whole lot to plan for now upon
release you will be able to make more
money by smithing dart tips so if that's
something you'd like to afk make sure to
do that within the first week of this
update being out because you'll be
making more money than you probably ever
will doing that method and on top of
that whenever this is released and old
school mobile is actually out a lot of
people will be killing gargoyles in
their spare time as far as making money
goes and with that you have a lot of
gold ore coming into the game so one
thing I would recommend if you want to
get a lot of smithing xp wait until
after the update gold ore prices will
drop and then you'll be able to swoop on
in and get really good GP / XP raids
next up is fishing fishing is going to
be one that is heavily impacted by this
fishing obviously one of the most common
skills within the game along with
cooking that people do in both
relatively afk now with fishing a lot of
people are gonna be doing quran' bonds
that's the way I see it it's a
money-making method you can make like
400 500 K an hour fishing it's great and
on top of that you know you get 50k XP
per hour it's really nice so a lot of
people will be doing this regardless of
the rates people will be doing this
because it's just a good fishing method
and it makes you money and it's really
really afk and so as more and more Kron
bonds come within the game the price of
every other food is going to fall no
matter where it is Coran bonds are
almost one of the best foods within the
game and so as their price dips other
foods will as well because no one will
be buying them if they can buy quorum
bonds instead so as far as cooking goes
cooking I imagine is one that's going to
be relatively unaffected obviously the
prices of cooked fish and uncooked fish
are going to go down but what I think's
going to happen is a margin between
uncooked to cook fish will stay
relatively the same since so many people
are going to be doing fishing that I
really don't think cooking it'd be all
too affected now with fire making we are
going to see some stuff happen and
obviously that's going to be in the form
of winter tot winter tot really afk so a
lot of people are going to be looking to
go there to try to
a little bit of levels and so with that
hopefully some seeds will come into the
game and seed prices will drop a little
bit I don't see it being all too drastic
sadly enough
ideally seed prices would drop a lot but
it's not really something I see
happening now and then lastly wood
cutting wood cutting is going to be one
eye I recommend to stay clear from
having any amount of logs within your
bank upon release pretty much everyone's
going to want to FK wood cutting
especially redwoods and magic stuff that
are higher tier trees just because
they're so afk so I'd recommend staying
away from having any amount of money
invested into any of this but one thing
I will say is as prices of logs go down
and as prices of cut logs go down as
well you are gonna have to see some sort
of thing happen to allow the strung
boughs to actually be worth there out
price because if the price of vlogs and
unstrung bows go down a ton both trees
are gonna have to go up because the I
out price of these items are already so
close to their price that you're going
to need something to actually recoup
what the high out price is so I would
definitely say that bow strings are a
good investment going into this even
though they've almost already hit their
peak right now at 160 GP per one so
that's it for this individual skills now
I'm going to go ahead and talk about
more of just some overall ones that I
see happening that I didn't cover
specifically in each of these skills so
the first thing I see happening is at
least upon release or within the first
week to month I do think that dragon
pickaxe prices are going to go up along
with dragon axe prices I recommend just
being heavily invested into those
especially dragon axes since sixty
woodcutting is pretty easily attainable
by almost everyone that plays the game
so dragon axe is probably going to go up
I would recommend that it's a really
good merch and as a side merge dragon
pickaxes could be doing pretty well as
well with mother lode mine being more
effective on the app on top of that and
unenchanted bolts are going to be
something I would recommend keeping an
eye on now whether you want to buy them
unenchanted now or actually put them
together each one you can do on your own
but basically what you do is all you
have to do is just do enchantments and
if you have two fingers which I'd
imagine most of us do you can just click
on the enchantment and then on the bolt
and if you have two fingers doing this
at once
it's insane magic XP so a lot of people
may be buying the unenchanted bolts to
be able to do this method so that's one
thing I'd also keep an eye out for now
another thing I didn't mention as far as
smithing is concerned I recommend highly
to stay on
into cannonballs I know cannonballs I've
hit all-time low right now and maybe
they end up going up a little bit but
once this is released cannonballs are
definitely going to go down because this
is going to be a money making method
that is three minutes of afk doing
absolutely nothing so a lot of people
are gonna be making cannonballs and I
think the price of those could go down
even more now the last all-encompassing
thing that I want to talk about is just
some overall afk money makers as far as
melee is concerned gargoyle drops wyvern
drops and green / blue dragons all of
those things are going to lose value and
in regards to their drops and what they
have dropped so I'd recommend staying
away from being invested into any of
those items as I think all of them are
hazardous because as more and more
people kill them they're obviously going
to be selling more and more of those
items thus the supplies going up demands
staying the same relatively so I'd say
overall probably best to say uninvested
into any of the items drop by those
monsters so in the end obviously these
are all just speculations by me I'm not
someone from the future so I can't
guarantee that any of these things will
happen but with the trends that I've
seen playing this game for the years
that I have these are all things that I
think are going to happen now I could be
wrong as to how many new players will be
playing on the app I obviously would be
all for having more and more people play
because it's just you know having that
noob community is such a nice thing to
have and it's something that we've been
missing for a while so I'm definitely
not against it I just don't think that's
going to happen as much and as far as
all of these things going up and down
based on the skills I think I'm
relatively close with a lot of them and
I think a lot of the things that I said
will ring true but if you guys have any
disagreements or anything else that you
guys would like to add as far as what
you think could be a good or bad
investment leave in the comments down
below if you guys enjoy my content make
sure to leave a like and on top of that
if you guys want to see more of it in
the future
subscribe to my channel but with that
said hopefully you guys have a wonderful
day and peace